[Music]
so I don't know if you know this about
me but I love quotes what am I
boring hey I love quotes everyone leaves
uh what I'm saying is over the years
I've collected some of my favorite
quotes that you might not be aware of
that I like to share with the viewing
public in a segment we call
[Applause]
[Music]
quotables yes all right first quote we
have here is quote time to fight fire
with
fire that's just a terrible fireman
that's a terrible terrible I feel you
getting settled in the idea of this
bit good get comfortable it's about 4
minutes quote I like my women like I
like my
coffee this one is a guy who likes to
Coffee
apparently
can I get an ice
coffee quote I'm kind of a big
deal that one is always a guy who's not
a big deal at
all at
all that's how you know he's not a big
deal this one is a two-parter uh quote
get her
done yeah that's just Larry the Cable
Guy
you're going to love the redneck bit we
do after this you are going to love it
this uh get or not done that's Larry the
Time Warner Cable
Guy how dare you provide our
Channel quote this is
bananas that's a guy at the zoo pointing
to the monkey
b a n a n a s that's quotable to
everybody
[Music]